as a side note
let me say a few words about the lab
leak hypothesis which proposes
that covet 19 is a product of gain of
function research
on coronaviruses conducted at the wuhan
institute of virology
that was then accidentally leaked due to
human error
for context this lab is biosafety level
4 bsl4
and it investigates coronaviruses bsl4
is the highest level of safety
but if you look at all the human and the
loop pieces required to achieve this
level of safety
it becomes clear that even bsl4 labs are
highly susceptible to human error
to me whether the virus leaked from the
lab or not getting to the bottom of what
happened is about much more
than this particular catastrophic case
it is a test
for our scientific political
journalistic and social institutions
of how well we can prepare and respond
to threats
that can [ __ ] or destroy human
civilization
if we continue to gain a function
research on viruses eventually
these viruses will leak and they will be
more deadly
and more contagious we can pretend that
won't happen
or we can openly and honestly talk about
the risks involved
this research can both save and destroy
human life on earth as we know it
it's a powerful double-edged sword if
youtube and other platforms
censor conversations about this if
scientists
self-censor conversations about this we
become merely victims
of our brief homo sapiens story not its
heroes
as i said before too carelessly labeling
ideas as misinformation
and dismissing them because of that will
eventually destroy our ability to
discover the truth
and without truth we don't have a
fighting chance
against the great filter before us
you